ba 112 la présidente moldave a dit que
l'estimé que ces explosions étaient dues
à des luttes re luttes de pouvoir à
l'intérieur de la transnistrie cette
république séparatiste qui en réalité
est occupé et contrôlé par la russie
depuis
1992 elle a dit que c'était l'hypothèse
qu'ils étudié pour le moment mais que
les informations continuer à se
recueillir elle a dit que la moldavie
renforcerait le dispositif sécuritaire
autour de la transnistrie que la
moldavie bien sûr rester ouverte au
dialogue pour essayer de trouver une
solution à ce conflit qui dure
maintenant depuis le début des années 90
et elle a aussi confirmé qu'il y avait
eu si vous voulez un quatrième explosion
il y a eu cette attaque à la grenade sur
un bâtiment gouvernemental dans la
capitale de la transnistrie tiraspol
hier et ce matin deux tours de radio qui
ont été détruits des tours de radio qui
imitaient les stations russe et puis
maya sens douai a confirmé qu'il y ait
aussi une explosion sur l'aérodrome de
tiraspol la capitale de la transnistrie